hi as it go and I'm Rob and today I'm
going to teach you how to solve a 4x4
Rubik's cube also known as the Rubik's
avenge solving 4x4 is a lot like solving
a 3x3 but there are some basic
principles and algorithms I recommend
you learn first on a 3x3 before
attempting a 4x4 if you don't know how
to solve the 3x3 I offer a tutorial on
my page that goes through how to solve
it in detail for beginners there's two
main differences I'd like to go through
between the 3 by 3 and the 4 by 4 if you
look at 3x3 it has one fixed center
piece per side that never moves that
means that yellow will always be
opposite white Green will always be
opposite blue and red will always be
opposite Orange if you have an East
Chien cube then opposite red you will
have purple instead of orange this does
not matter I would like you to however
memorize those color pairs as it will
prove useful when you're placing the
center's on the 4x4
so let's look at the 4x4 if you see the
center of the 4x4 is composed of four
different pieces what that means is that
the Centers of the 4x4 can actually move
and they're not fixed in place which
means that you're going to have to
actually place them before you can
continue and solve the cube will also
notice that it has eight edges per side
as opposed to four on the 3x3 that means
that they can split up and you're going
to have to pair them with their
complementary piece before you can
actually solve the cube once you pair
the edges and fix the center's you'll
get something that resembles a 3x3 cube
that had been mixed up this can
basically be solved as a 3x3 with the
exception of something we'll call parity
that we'll go over it later
some of the notation I'd like to go over
for the cube is because there are four
layers on the cube so it has what we
call inside layers this is an outside
layer and this layer here would be
called an inside layer that's called the
inside up layer so if I told you to turn
the inside up layer clockwise the inside
up layer we're going to denote as little
u the outside up layer is denoted as big
u so if I told you to turn the inside of
layer clockwise that would look
something like that
you could turn it two different ways I
find it easier to kind of turn that like
that and then turn the top back
if I told you to turn both right faces
clockwise that would look something like
that that would be denoted as big R
little R in parentheses if I told you to
turn both up faces the inside up and the
outside up face counterclockwise
that would be denoted by big you little
U in parentheses followed by an
apostrophe and that would look something
like that and of course if I just told
you to turn the right outer face
clockwise that would look something like
that if I told you to turn the up face
count 180 degrees that would look
something like that that's just basic
notation from learning how to solve a
3x3 now we'll go on to solve the
center's okay so for placing the
center's it does come in handy if you
know that color pairing scheme that I
just talked about because this step is
fairly intuitive you're not going to
have to know any algorithms what I first
try to do is I try to place three
centers in a clockwise direction on the
cube that's a total of 12 pieces the
centers I like to use our red white and
blue because it's easiest for me to
memorize but you can choose any three
you like as long as you place them in
the same position and direction as they
exist in the solved cube so let me
explain what I mean by that because red
white and blue exists in the clockwise
direction on the salt cube you can place
it like that you can also do red green
and white if you wanted to you could not
flip these two and place green red and
white in a clockwise direction you would
not be able to solve that cube so there
are three main things what you have to
do when solving the center's you're
going to have to make a two by one block
you're going to have the join to 2x1
blocks and you're going to have to join
a single piece occasionally with what I
like to call a three piece L so the
first thing I like to do is to create
the red center and work from there so
what I like to do is I like to find a
red piece that is on the front and join
it with a red piece that is on the top
what you have to do is look at the
relative position of this red piece it's
in the lower left what you're going to
have to realize is that in order to join
this piece to that piece this piece has
to be in the lower right so if they're
both in the same position right now this
is the lower left of
top phase this is the lower left of the
front you're not going to be able to
join it also if you if it was there you
wouldn't be able to join it either if it
was up there when you when you cross it
it will be diagonally so what you have
to do is this is the lower left you have
to position this in the lower right then
when you flip it up it will form a 2x1
block so now we have one 2x1 block we
want to form another one actually we
have one already solved for us here so
in order to join it we put them in
opposite sides of the cube so this is
vertically on the right side of the cube
let's put this one vertically on the
left side of the cube then we can turn
it 180 degrees and join it together to
make a 2x2 red centre what we want to do
next is to place the white center it
could be any position that you want as
long as it's next to the red so let's
use this position we have a piece here
in the front and a piece in the top and
they are in the right positions that we
want to in order to join them so this
one's in lower left and this one is in
the lower right so we can join them and
you want to make sure that you're not
disturbing that red center that you just
formed and we're not going to so we just
want a white 2x1 block now we want to
form another one so here's one in the
front face and here's one in the top
this one is in the upper right this one
is in the lower left so what we have to
do is make this one in the upper left so
we turn the top now this one can join up
with this one but you have to be careful
because when you turn it it's going to
mess up this red center so once you form
it and you see it's horizontal like that
you turn it vertically like that then
you could put these two back down and
yuri saw that red center so now we have
a 2x1 white block here and we have
another 2x1 white block there what we do
is we can bring this one up here in
order to do that we can't just join it
by putting this one on the left side and
this one on the right side because as
you'll see when you turn it you messed
up the red completely so what you do in
this case is you put them in the same
side so that you put them both on the
right side in the same plane or the same
layer if you can call it so right now
they're on the same layer so we flip it
and we take those two out so we kick
those two out we turn the top 180
degrees and now when we turn them back
it will be right next to it and it will
bring the red along with it so now we
have the red and the white now we need
to place the blue when you have two
pieces like that diagonally in the same
face what you do is you take the one on
top in the upper and the upper layer and
you bring it to the top face like that
then you look at the position of this
one this one is in the lower lower left
so this one is now in the upper right
you want to bring it down to the lower
right so you bring it down to the lower
right ignore this piece here will be
forming a two by one block with that
later so then we bring it down and we
formed another two by one block now we
want to form another two by one blue
block so here's one piece and that's in
the front face and here's another piece
in the top face this one is in the upper
right and this one is in the upper left
which is good so when you join them you
have to also be sure that you're not
disturbing that red center here so when
you join it and you see it horizontal
all you got to do is turn vertically and
then you could pop this back down to fix
the red Center so now we have another
two by one blue block so we have the red
the white this has to be the blue center
so now what we have to do is again
because this red is going to interfere
with us just flipping this up like that
we have to put them on the same side so
this blue is on the left side we'll put
it on the right side like the one in the
top face so we'll put it in the right
side like that so now when we bring this
up and kick that out and flip it around
180 degrees we can bring this back like
that and it will join up with the one
that just kicked it out so now we have
the red the white and the blue solved so
now that color pairing scheme comes in
handy so opposite the blue goes the
green so here we have a three piece L as
I like to call it now in order to join
the the green piece the solo piece
that's alone which is right here
with this three-piece L we have to get
this this piece that's alone into the
bottom right or the bottom left so right
now it's on the right side so all we got
to do is bring it down to get it on the
bottom right and what we need to do now
is you need to look at the corner of
this L the corner of the L is here it's
in the upper right you need to get it in
the same position that it is that this
piece is here in the front face so this
is in the lower right so you turn this
until that corner piece is also in the
lower right now what you can do is you
could bring this turn the right face and
you meet up this piece with that lone
piece this is a pair here and this is
kind of a lone piece so you bring it up
and you match it with that lone piece
then you turn it vertically now if you
kicked it out and these two pieces were
on the right side you want these two
pieces to be on the left side so when
you bring these two pieces back down it
will meet up so now we have the green
now what we want to do opposite the red
goes the purple in my case you might
have orange so if I want to join these
together what I have to do is again put
them in the same plane
and then when I bring these up to meet
with those I kick them out turn the top
180 degrees and then I bring the right
back down so now as you'll see if you
had something similar to mine that you
should have all the Centers should be
solved this is pretty intuitive so
you're going to have to play around with
it a little bit if you didn't get a case
that's very similar to mine but those
are the basic cases that you're going to
be getting the the L with the one piece
or basically just two of those 2x1
blocks that you'll have to join together
so the next next step we're going to be
solving these edges we're going to be
pairing them up